ce monument a été élevé par l'enpi
maintenu par la restauration décoré par
louis philippe est conservée par la
république
le 15 décembre 1840 le cortège qui
accompagnait les centres de l'empereur
ramené de sainte-hélène s'arrêta sous
cette voûte où sont gravés les noms de
660 généraux et ceux de 128 bataille ce
fut le retour d'austerlitz que napoléon
ordonna l'édification de cet arc de
triomphe colossal
il est le symbole de l' empire à son
apogée
mais l'histoire n'est pas comme les
monuments elle ne fixe pas uniquement
certains instants privilégiés de la vie
ou de l'oeuvre de ses héros elle déroule
de la naissance à la mort
l'enchevêtrement des événements qui
constituent une vie seul celui qui se
garde de son imagination et croire à la
fatalité comprendra le sens de cette
geste écrite par la main du destin que
fut l'épopée impérial et c'est ici que
tout a commencé ici dans la maison
bonaparte dans l'ain kasab ou un appart
et plus précisément dans cette pièce où
nous sommes puisque c'est ici que
napoléon est né le 15 août 1769 dans
cette maison bonaparte comment
était-elle à cette époque
d'abord la petite rue par laquelle on y
accède cette petite rue était bordée de
l'autre côté par des maisons il n'y
avait pas le jardin le square que l'on y
voit actuellement
c'était donc une ruelle spécifiquement
méditerranéenne spécifiquement corse
dans la très ancienne tradition cette
maison ne sait pas on ne sait pas très
exactement quand elle a été construite
sans doute au début du xviiie siècle et
elle est entrée dans la famille
bonaparte en 1743 qui étaient ces
bonaparte d'où venaient-ils il ya des
tas de légende naturellement autour d'un
grand homme mais napoléon est un grand
homme de la première catégorie si je
vous dis on this évidemment infiniment
de légende alors on on veut que nous les
bonaparte soit par exemple les héritiers
d empereur de byzance c'est évidemment
tout à fait fou on veut qu'ils
descendent d'une illustre famille
italienne
à sierre les cadeaux linge on en a pas
de preuve en vérité le premier but à la
parts et francesc au bout un appart le
premier dont on trouve la trace en corse
c'est française que bonaparte qui vient
en 490 au milieu du xviiie siècle
le représentant de la famille bonaparte
je lis bien bio à la partie puisque ce
n'est que bien après que napoléon france
y sera son nom et de buonaparte fera
bonaparte il en présentant des débuts un
appart c'est charles carles aux autres
modes charles bonaparte qui est né en
1946 qui a fait ses études à corte est
cependant que grandit charles bonaparte
la corse est plongé dans un climat de
tension et de révolte car la corse
dépens de gênes et la corse ne supporte
pas la domination de gênes alors on
s'insurge on se bat et il a manqué
longtemps à la corse un chef à l'époque
où charles bonaparte grandi ce chef
s'est trouvée il s'appelle pascal paoli
pascal paoli chasse les génois et la
corse est quasiment indépendante mais en
1764 gène appelle la france à l'aide et
des bataillons français commandé par
marboeuf des bars gays
c'est cette année-là que charles
bonaparte épouse letizia ramolino
ravissante jeune fille âgée seulement de
14 ans
[Musique]
il s'installe dans la case à bonaparte
dont il n'occupe que le rez-de-chaussée
et le premier étage au dessus d'eux
habite leurs cousins pozzo di borgo et
au dernier étage vie le chef de la tribu
un vieil oncle l'archidiacre lucien
bonaparte
les premières années du mariage sont
difficiles laetitia trop jeunes mettent
au monde deux enfants mort nés et
surtout c'est la guerre gênes a
complètement cédé l'île à la france mais
les corses farouchement indépendant ne
l'entendent pas ainsi
paoli réuni un conseil des notables
charles bonaparte qui en fait partie
un site la jeunesse corse à la révolte
tout le pays soulève et se bat contre
les troupes françaises qui sont tout
d'abord tenu en effet le 9 mai 17 ans
représentent 9
c'est la bataille ultime
le dernier affrontement entre les corses
et les français c'est la défaite c'est
la défaite pour la corse le soir même de
la bataille en petits groupes sans fille
son fils dans la montagne on ne veut pas
tomber entre les mains des français dans
ce petit cop il ya des hommes et une
femme
il ya charles bonaparte il y à laetitia
bonaparte il gravit la montagne gravi la
montagne arrive au sommet du monte
rotondo live resteront pendant plusieurs
jours dans une grotte s'abritant dans
une grotte et il y a quelque chose
d'extraordinaire sur le monte rotonde
c'est que de ce sommet on voit à la fois
l'île d'elbe l'italie et la force toutes
les étapes
si l'on exclut évidemment sainte-hélène
toutes les étapes d'un destin prodigieux
et pendant ce temps pendant ces jours
d'attenté
laetitia dira que cet enfant elles
portent s'agite beaucoup le sentir à
s'agiter en elle et elle dit aussi à
cette époque qu'elle déteste les
français
elle dira il sera karl pense que c'est
un fils il sera le vengeur de la corse
paoli s'est embarquée c'en est fini du
destin corse de paoli il partira pour
l'angleterre et il faut se résoudre à
traiter mais les français d'ailleurs
font des propositions aux corses ils
disent maintenant oublions le passé il
n'y aura pas de vengeance
ralliez vous et charles bonaparte d'un
seul coup se décide à ce rallye on
arrive juste à temps
c'est l'été on était triste mélancolique
laetitia repris possession de sa maison
arrive au terme de sa grossesse
le kazoo fête de la vierge et dans les
pays méditerranéens c'est une fête
célébrée avec plus d'enthousiasmé encore
qu'ailleurs le 15 août 1769 laetitia
décide d'aller assister un la cathédrale
notre dame toute proche d'ailleurs à la
grand messe et tout à coup au milieu de
la messe un malaise un malaise qu'elle
connaît bien puisqu'elle elle a déjà eu
en plus de ses enfants mort-nés joseph
l'année précédente
et là elle se précipite avec sa cuisine
gertrude part avec chine il se précipite
elles courent vers la maison elle arrive
elle a à peine le temps de monter au
premier étage et elle s'arrête elle n'a
pas le temps d'aller vers son lit est
sûre ce canapé
ce canapé qu'on conserve toujours elles
accouchent sans même l'aide d'une
sage-femme
c'est gertrude paravicini qu'il
assistera la sage femme arrivera trop
tard alors plus tard on racontera parce
que toujours la légende on racontera que
on a déposé le bébé napoléon sur un
tapis qui représentait une scène de
l'illiade c'était magnifique à raconter
mais madame laetitia robuste femme corse
avec tout son bon sens dira mais il n'y
avait pas de tapis dans nos maisons de
corse
[Musique]
avec les années qui passent les
naissances se succèdent
il y en aura huit en tout mais trop
d'enfants en bas âge dans une petite
maison rendent la vie difficile
aussi dès l'âge de 4 ans napoléon amis
chez les soeurs puis dans une école
tenue par un certain abbé rego
[Musique]
oui
et tandis que nous visitons la casa
bonaparte il importe de nous souvenir
que charles bonaparte a fait de son
mieux pour élever ses enfants
je n'ai pas ce que ça ferme des millet
ligne ses vignes de la sposata lui
rapporte la famille manque d'argent il
assiège dont les bureaux du gouverneur
marboeuf pour faire reconnaître sa
noblesse et il finit par être nommé un
assesseur auprès de la juridiction royal
d'ajaccio
puis les enfants grandissant il demande
et obtient deux bourses pour ses deux
fils aîné joseph étant destiné à faire
des études ecclésiastiques et napoléon
une carrière militaire en 1778 nommé
représentants de la noblesse corse
charles doit se rendre à versailles
auprès du roi l'occasion est excellente
pour emmener joseph et napoléon sur le
continent alors un petit garçon corse
âgé de 9 ans qui ne parlent pas le
français va un beau jour s'embarquer à
bastia avec son frère aîné son père sur
le quai laetitia bonaparte agitera
longuement son mouchoir
elle sait qu'elle ne reverra plus ses
deux fils avant plusieurs années
ces années seront difficiles pour elle
très difficile car son mari ambitieux
cherche à se pousser il reçoit beau or
elle qui a la charge du ménage à très
peu d'argent
elle est donc obligé d'économiser sur
tout ce qui concerne la vie usuelle de
la famille
elle acquiert râle un trait de caractère
dont elle ne se départira jamais même au
milieu des fastes de l' empire et l'on
parlera alors de son avarice
il se passera cinq en cinq ans avant que
laeticia et charles revoir leur fils
joseph et napoléon
charles part pour la france laetitia
l'accompagnent elles le seront avec
charles à brienne elle embrasse enfin
son petit napoléon
là il s'est passé cinq ans
[Musique]
et puis deux ans plus tard napoléon
reviendra à ajaccio est donc resté huit
ans éloigné d'ajaccio entre temps s'est
produit un événement que napoléon a
ressenti profondément son père est mort
on ne sait pas exactement de quoi
sûrement d'un ulcère à l'estomac
peut-être d'un cancer joseph devenait le
chef de famille napoléon ne pensais pas
en ce temps-là être le chef de famille
et il faut le voir arriver sur le port
ici ajaccio avec son épaule est tout
neuf en habit de lieutenant d'artillerie
sa mère l'a tant ses frères l'attend ses
soeurs l'attendent les cousins attendent
car c'est le clan c'est le clan il faut
jamais oublier quand on raconte
l'histoire de napoléon
la force du clan en corse
il revient qu'on se disant que c'est là
que sera un jour sa vie car à cette
époque ce jeune homme pense qu'il doit
faire son destin en corse
il a écrit au possède un écrit de lui
qui date exactement cette époque dans
lequel il souhaite que les corses
un beau jour se soulève et qu'ils
chassent les français définitivement de
corse
voilà donc son état d'esprit quand sa
jeune homme revient chez lui dans sa
chair casabo un appart et dans ses
chairs milelli qui va retrouver au fin
[Musique]
les 1000 lits sont une propriété située
à moins de cinq kilomètres du centre
d'ajaccio
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la maison et ses dépendances
sont totalement englobé dans la ville et
offre aux visiteurs un magnifique parc
planté d'oliviers
[Musique]
nous sommes ici au mit les lie c'est à
dire la ferme des baux n'a pas c'est une
maison qui à l'époque était assez
grandiose comme une ferme vous le voyez
qu'ils avaient plusieurs états et que la
municipalité d'ajaccio se préoccupent
actuellement de restaurer et elle
appartenait à un parent de la mère de
charles bonaparte un certain odone celui
ci avait légué cette maison aux jésuites
et quand les jésuites furent expulsés de
france charles bonaparte réclament à
cette maison comme un bien familial
il faut dire qu il plaida pendant des
années jusqu'à sa mort en 1985 sans
résultat mais au moment où il mûri il
avait obtenu tout de même que cette
maison lui soient cédés à bail un bail
emphytéotique en quelque sorte la
famille bonaparte en devenait
propriétaire et c'est ici dans cette
maison d'emile elie que le jeune
napoléon bonaparte
lorsqu'il revenait en permission du
continent venaient méditer il aimait il
aimait cette ferme il aimait ce pays il
aimait les environs il aimait voir la
mer et c'est ici qu'il travaillait
également qu'il lisait qu'il écrivait ce
qui est frappant c'est que c'est dans
cette maison dans cette ferme d'emilie
qu'il a écrit son premier pamphlet cette
lettre abouta focaux bouddha faut qu
était le député de la noblesse de corse
aux états généraux est tout à fait aux
côtés d'un ennemi de paoli à cette
époque napoléon était favorable à paoli
et ils avaient attaqué violemment
botafogo dans cette lettre datée de son
cabinet des milices qui était un peu un
terme pompeux mais enfin évidemment ça
faisait impressions sur le continent
lorsqu'il publia cette brochure est ce
qui permet de penser qu'on vient
napoléon et mais cette maison c'est que
lors de son retour d'égypte il s'arrête
à ajaccio il va avec l'âne notamment et
murat passé ici deux jours ce furent les
derniers jours qu'il passa dans sa chair
maison des 1000 m mais les milelli
n'était pas seulement une maison
d'agrément c'était un domaine de rapport
dont les produits étaient indispensables
à la vie des bonaparte l'huile d'olive
le vin le lait le fromage et la viande
de brebis assurer les besoins familiaux
les excédents été vendues ou troquer
contre des denrées que la ferme ne
produisait pas
[Musique]
après sa permission bonaparte est rentré
dans sa garnison métropolitaine c'est à
ce moment que s'est produit un événement
immense la révolution napoléon se
passionne et s'enthousiasment pour les
idées de pelle à l'automne de 1789
le jeune officier d'artillerie revient
en corse avec un sens très précis de
l'action qu'il va mener dès le début de
son séjour ils forment un comité
patriotique l'arrivée de napoléon va
coïncider avec une autre arrivée ou à
peu près ce que semaine près c'est celle
de pascal paoli
et oui l'exil et le vaincu de pontet
nouveau l'homme qui est en angleterre
depuis ce temps-là a été réintégré dans
ses droits car l'assemblée sur
l'impulsion de mirabeau à voter
pourrait-on dire son amnistie et il ya
d'ailleurs une lettre extraordinaire du
jeune napoléon à paroles qui date
également de cette époque le jeune
napoléon et cria paoli toute son
admiration et rappelle son existence au
vieux gbagbo et lui dit cette phrase il
lui écrit cette phrase je naquis quand
la patrie périssé voilà qui nous situe
bien encore une fois la psychologie de
napoléon la patrie c'est la corse est
pas du tout là vous et paoli qui revient
en corse au milieu d'un triomphe
absolument délirant c'est pour le jeune
napoléon le signe le signe que de
nouveaux la corse va exister et que lui
son destin va pouvoir s'épanouir dans sa
course dans sa chaire gosse la première
entrevue entre un napoléon et paoli
n'est pas extrêmement agréable pour la
peau les os
il faut dire qu'il s'est montré
maladroit c'est un très jeune homme ne
l'oublions pas est pile un caractère qui
commence à se dessiner
d'une manière très précise alors il
demande à perly d'évoquer la bataille de
ponte nouveau et paoli donne le plan de
cette bataille et je ne parle et on ne
peut pas s'empêcher de commenter
alors je ne m'étonne pas du résultat
darmenté pas très agréable en temps pour
paoli à dessus napoléon lui dit qu'il a
commencé à écrire une histoire de la
corse et paoli lance monsieur l'histoire
ne s'écrit pas dans les années de
jeunesse
ç'a commencé assez mal et pourtant paoli
ne pouvait pas oublier charles bonaparte
son ami charles l'homme qui l'avait
défendu
napoléon est maintenant ajaccio son rêve
son désir c'est de s'y installer
mais il faut bien qu'il rentre à son
régiment alors il repeint il sert dans
sa garnison mais visiblement il ne fait
ça que pour ne pas être en faute il ne
fait ça que parce qu autrement ils
risqueraient d'être cassés de son grade
mais on peut penser que dès le moment où
il rote où il met le pied nouveau sur le
territoire continental
il espère pouvoir retourner et il faut
dire que très peu de mois plus tard il
obtient une nouvelle permission
on laisse reste rêveur sur l'état de
l'art mais à cette époque quand on voit
comment très jeune officier comme
napoléon bonaparte peut obtenir tout le
temps des permissions et des permissions
qui dure trois mois ça mois six mois
et le voilà de nouveau le voilà en corse
[Musique]
deux siècles plus tard napoléon est
toujours en corse
[Musique]
pour la plus grande satisfaction des
touristes et pour le légitime orgueil
des corses
il est ici partout omniprésent par ses
effigies ses titres sa famille ses
victoires
l'épopée a franchi le cap de la légende
et cette légende c'est gravé dans la
pierre sur la place publique ou coin des
rues au fronton des cinémas à l'enseigne
des restaurants c'est la matérialisation
populaire de l'histoire
ajaccio et la ville livres d'histoire
impérial plus de pages à tourner il
suffit de déambuler de flâner au gré des
quais des rues et des avenues comme dans
un dictionnaire à ciel ouvert le
visiteur étourdi devrait alors se
rémémorer la phrase de goethe
la légende napoléonienne et comme la
révélation de saint jean
chacun sent qu'il s'y cachent encore
autre chose mais personne ne sait quoi
[Musique]
e
m
si aujourd'hui les livres les
porcelaines les articles de bureau
contribuent par leur imagerie entretenir
le souffle épique en septembre 1791
bonaparte n'était encore entrer ni dans
l'épopée ni dans la légende
il était revenu en permission en corse
avec un but très précis se faire élire
lieutenant colonel de la garde nationale
ajaccio ce qui lui permettrait de
choisir son poste et de ne plus quitter
son île natale
[Musique]
il ya une campagne électorale et ça dieu
sait si j'aime la corse et les corses
j'y suis quand j'y viens chez moi mais
il faut dire que il ya une tradition des
campagnes électorales encore ce que nous
connaissons bien et bien elle existe
déjà à ce moment là c'est pas pour
l'élection de la peau les os c'est tout
à fait ordinaire il y à des enlèvements
il est un commissaire qui est hostile
aux bonaparte alors on l'enlève
littéralement et on ne rit on l'emmène
dans une maison dont on ne peut plus
sortir alors le lendemain un autre
commissaire qui se répand propos en
disant que c'est une honte qui fois nue
les églises et les élections il est
interdit aux électeurs de pénétrer en
armes dans la salle du vote alors
naturellement il met qu'ils ont tous des
armes car on ne sait jamais attention
dans une campagne électorale
les armes sont cachés sous leur avis
tout ça a un côté mon dieu finalement
séduisant amusant et ne détonne pas dans
le folklore traditionnel de la corse est
finalement peut-être grâce à ça
peut-être grâce aux amis peut-être grâce
à l'enlèvement de moratti est bien la
peau les os et élus malheureusement il
n'est pas élu lieutenant-colonel en
premier c'est un certain quenza qu'était
le lieutenant-colonel lui il était le
lieutenant colonel en 2d et sa situation
dès l'origine n'est pas celle qu'il
espérait d'ailleurs on se méfie de cette
garde nationale paoli qui domine
maintenant la corse qui s'est fait élire
à la fois au commandement civil et
militaire de l'accord ce qui est tout à
fait légal d'ailleurs où ça ne fait rien
et bien par olic se méfie décidément de
ce petit bonaparte paoli est un
conservateur paoli est un homme trahi
sionnel et paoli même pas le sens que
prend la révolution française
il n'aime pas ces gens qui se rallient à
cette révolution qui lui fait peur or
napoléon bonaparte sa famille ses amis
sont pour cette révolution alors comment
le fossé ne s'agrandit de rethel et pas
entre paoli et bois la porte et on va
faire partir la garde nationale pour
corte napoléon se rendra compte qu'à ce
moment là il ne peut disposer d'aucune
autorité est plutôt que de ne pas
commander chez lui il préfère abandonner
provisoirement le terrain et il repart
et il repart pour le continent nous
sommes cette fois le 28 mai 1792 ceux
qui regardent le bateau s'éloigner ne
savent pas que les jours que le jeune
officier va vivre sur le continent vont
être mouvementé d'abord il va être fait
capitaine puis au mois d'août
il assistera à la prise des tuileries
devant l'incapacité du roi a sauvé la
situation alors que celui-ci en est
bonaparte lui appliquera le plus bref
qualificatif de la langue française
il ira enfin chercher à saint cyr sa
soeur marianne a pour la ramener en
corse et lui éviter de passer cette
période troublée loin de sa famille
dans cette agitation extrême napoléon
sens qu'il faut vraiment prendre parti
il va essayer de se rapprocher de poli
mais en vain car celui ci s'éloigne de
plus en plus de la révolution et de la
france
au début tu 93 c'est la guerre
d'ailleurs la guerre que la france
involys ionnaires déclaré à l'europe des
rois on est en guerre notamment avec le
roi de sardaigne et avant de lancer une
opération sur la sardaigne on a décidé
de s'emparer d'une petite île entre la
corse et la sardaigne l'île de la matte
d'haleine et napoléon avec d'autres est
désigné pour conduire
l'expédition contre la madeleine et par
suite d'erreurs mais le mot erreur
dissimule bien des machinations ce sera
un échec
visiblement pas au lit ne voulais pas
que l'on remporte une victoire à la
madeleine
napoléon qui a participé à ce premier
engagement c'est sa première bataille
la première bataille de ce grand homme
de guerre et cette première bataille est
un échec et lui qui a été la rentrer en
corse définitivement amer définitivement
sur ie contre paoli et de ce moment date
le moment où il a choisi la choisit la
révolution il a choisi la france
un autre bonaparte avait également
choisi lucien un des jeunes frère de
napoléon secrétaire de sénou ville est
arrivé à toulon à la tribune des clubs
révolutionnaire il a dénoncé paoli comme
traîtres à la patrie
cette dénonciation atteint paris où la
convention lance un décret de mise en
accusation contre paoli et son adjoint
pozzo di borgo
l'arrivée de ce décret en corse soulève
l'indignation de la population qui a
toujours vu en paoli son libérateur les
pas aux listes intercepte une lettre de
lucien à sa mère dans laquelle il
reconnaît être la cause de toute la
sphère il se retourne alors contre la
famine dans la nuit du 24 au 25 mai 1793
un ami fait irruption en pleine nuit il
annonce que les pas aux listes ont
décidé de s'en prendre la famille de
napoléon
ils vont attaquer la maison il faut fuir
il faut fuir à tout prix alors laetitia
décide de partir
la nuit même ls les deux plus petites
ces enfants c'est-à-dire jérôme et
pauleta paulette
lls à une parente et avec les autres
elle part à travers le maquis à pied
dans la nuit elle part pour les 1000
elie la maison si chère à charles si
chère à napoléon leur faudra deux heures
deux heures à pied pour gagner cette
maison
laëtitia ne reverra plus la casa
bonaparte dans l'état où elle la quitte
tout ici sera dévasté et pillé meubles
vaisselle linge tout jusqu aux
huisseries des portes et des fenêtres
disparu
et nous qui à chevaux maintenant de
visiter les quatre piège du premier
étage il importe que nous sachions que
les meubles actuelle furent acquis en
1797 avec les 90 7500 francs
d'indemnités que touche à madame
bonaparte sur les 3 millions que le
directoire accorda aux révolutionnaires
corse pour les préjudices subis ces
meubles et ce décor ne sont donc pas
ceux de l'enfance de napoléon il ne
devait les connaître qu'à son retour
d'égypte lorsque les vents le
contraignirent le 1er octobre 17 199 à
faire escale à ajaccio mais lorsque
laetitia abandonner sa maison elle ne
songeait ni assez meuble ni à sa
vaisselle ni à son linge elle ne pensait
qu'à sauver la vie de ces enfants est la
sienne elle n'avait qu'un but aller
chercher un refuge qu'elle croyait sur
dans sa ferme des millet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a passé ici la nuit et tout à coup on
voit on n'entend plus tôt arrivés à
cheval
l'abbé coty un ami du clan un ami de la
famille il est également procureur
syndic du district l'abbé coty arrivent
en disant les pas aux listes ont cerné
la maison ils ont fait une enquête
vous êtes dénoncer les pas aux listes
arrivent ils vont venir vous enlevez ici
aux mille et lit il faut fuir
que va faire laetitia laetitia se pose
évidemment la question on l'informent en
même temps que napoléon fait voile avec
les conventionnels vers ajaccio donc le
salut si ça lui il y as ne peut venir
que de la mer il faut donc gagner la mer
c'est donc laetitia qui décide de partir
le soir en attendant que la nuit soit
venu pour gagner le maquis on va gagner
à travers le maquis la mer au delà de la
thur du capital au même plus loin et
éventuellement pour essayer de rejoindre
napoléon
[Musique]
on se dirige à travers le maquis d'abord
vers le capitaine l'eau le capitaine
l'eau qui est un temps son cours a été
gonflée par les pluies torrentielles qui
sont tombées récemment comment traverser
cette aurore costa se souvient que l'un
de ses amis qui s'appelle rocha habite
non loin de là et qu'il possède un
chevalet c'est sur ce cheval que
laëtitia d'abord ses enfants suite
passeront un après l'autre ce torrent
vers minuit les enfants épuisés pleurs
impossible d'aller plus loin pour doit
fermer et pendant cette halte on entend
le bruit de gens qui arrivent
ce sont des pas aux listes on se cache
dans un petit bois kotil plus mort que
vif entend les paolis dire il faut tu
écoutes aux menaces des pires sanctions
mais peut à l'aparté laetitia entendent
il irait bien nous allons piller leurs
réseaux on imagine son état d'esprit
pendant cette nuit puis l'on repart on
marchera toute la nuit on marchera toute
la journée du lendemain est enfin à la
fin de cette journée
voici coti chiavari un petit village
pour le dépasse et l'on arrive à un mot
qui s'appelle casey l'art il ya une
maison de trois maisons au maximum ce
hameau est placé sur l'isthme de caponné
moore en pleine mer or laëtitia le
cécilia salue ce salut viendra de la
mûre dans cette petite mais cette petite
maison ne peut pas rêver le plus petit
et c'est là que cette femme laeticia
arrive avec louis avec mariana et deux
enfants avec la bêche l'abbé cote ces
lacs qui sont restés pendant 6 jours 6
jours à regarder la mer six jours
d'angoissé jour de peur se dire mais en
fait ce qu'on va nous rejoindre ou pas
cette maison l'habite toujours c'est
madame comment vous appelez-vous madame
andriuzzi j'ai dit vous avez quel âge
voilà et attraits vingt six ans est ce
que vous pouvez demander à madame si on
lui a parlé de cette maison vous pouvez
vous les indépendants tous et impulse a
toujours parlé et puis il est toujours
et elle est toujours habité là vous êtes
né ici va vendre ou non elles et les
pannes et cissé mallié l'été mais andré
you tu sais malien ici avec un 1 2 août
ah oui et vous avez vécu toute votre vie
ou toute sa vie ici qu'est ce qu'on vous
ai dit madame qu'est ce qu'on vous a dit
quand vous étiez enfant sur la présence
de laëtitia et sa famille si vous voulez
vous demander à madame qui liquidity
hannigan de terrain yohan aguédé
reichstag il est attendu qu'il était
venu ici et qu'il était prêt à rester là
ils n'ont pas une semaine deux semaines
l'histoire d'ici jours mais la tradition
du 8 mai ça la tradition de l'histoire
ça fait deux et est-ce qu'il y avait
encore quand vous étiez petit des
souvenirs ou voulez-vous demander à
madame s'il y avait des souvenirs ici et
là la zone rouge car il allie de cette
assiette vous devez manger et qu'est-ce
que devenu cette année disparue après
les enfants il est
il est disparue ce qui n'a pas disparu
en revanche c'est cette maison où nous
allons a très mal âme si vous le
permettez cette maison où ce qui nous
stupéfie d'abord c'est son exiguïté ces
plafonds si bas hélas cette poutre cette
poutre dont on est vraiment sûr qu'elle
n'a pas changé que n'a pas bougé depuis
que laëtitia ces enfants sont restés ici
et passons dans cette petite chambre on
peut dire qu'au delà de three douce
c'est une chance il ya délit et oui
évidemment l'ennemi ne sont pas à
l'époque les les tableaux non plus les
photographies non plus les souvenirs non
plus mais il faut imaginer fatalement
qu'il y avait là aussi des lits et par
conséquent pendant plusieurs jours
laetitia vécu ici exactement ce cadre il
y avait là donc la future madame madame
mère de l'empereur est roi il y avait là
louis le futur roi de hollande
il y avait là mariana qui s'appellera un
jour et lisa qui sera grande duchesse de
l'udc
il y avait là la belle flèche qui sera
cardinal qui sera archevêque de lyon et
primat des gaules et c'est là je crois
dans un cadre comme celui-ci conques ont
saisi beaucoup mieux tout ce qui est
extraordinaire dans cette épopée de la
famille bonaparte il faut avoir vu une
maison comme celle ci je n'avais jamais
est vraiment ce que je ressens ici c'est
le côté unique dans l'histoire
littéralement stupéfiants de cette
ascension
napoléon avait quitté avec la flotte de
la convention bastia avec les
conventionnels la combe saint michel et
saint lys et petits le but c'était
ajaccio voulait reprendre la ville
d'ajaccio pas aux listes une tempête a
retenu la flotte en mer ils ne sont
arrivés que plusieurs jours plus tard
devant ajaccio c'était trop tard on a
essayé de prendre contact avec ce qui
restait de patriotes à ajaccio aucune
réponse
il a fallu se replier en longeant la mer
ici sur le bateau sur ce bateau qui
portait évidemment à la pompe un
pavillon républicain que napoléon est
passé sous la petite fenêtre de cette
maison laetitia et les siens gaieté
avait les yeux fixés sur la mer et ce
bateau qui avait un drapeau républicain
pour eux c'était le salut alors voyons
ce bateau ils ont fait l'essai napoléon
les a vus ces c'est à ce moment là la
famille est descendu a couru a couru
dans la petite crique sous la tour sous
la tour de capo di muro la napoléon le
bateau n'a pas pu s'approcher n'y avait
pas assez de tirant d'eau qu'on l'a mis
une chaloupe à la mer napoléon est
descendu dans cette chaloupe napoléon le
savais pas au départ que c'était sa
famille l'avait vu des gens qui faisait
des signes s'était dit ce sont des
patriotes qui fuient les pas aux listes
mais quand il a vu que c'était sa mère
son frère sa soeur alors lie dans la
chaloupe il n'a pas eu la patience
d'arriver jusqu'au rivage
il a sauté dans l'eau il a couru
laetitia nous voyons arriver se
souviendra elle avait plus de 85 ans tu
me raconteras cela plus tard à la reine
hortense que quand il s'était jeté dans
ses bras le dire oui ils étaient tous
vides à 1080 se souvenait de service qui
l'a sauvé tout mouillé et c'est ici
c'est ici que l'on peut je crois le
mieux rêver sur le destin de napoléon et
sa famille car sur ce bateau ils vont
partir ils vont partir pour calvi ils y
resteront
du 3 au 11 juin gardant encore un peu
d'espoir peut-être la situation sera
telle rétabli peut-être pourra-t-on
encore l'emporter sur les pas au lit sur
les pas aux listes mais non on comprend
peu à peu que lille est perdue pour les
bonaparte et le 11 juin
napoléon sa famille partiront pour
toulon napoléon tournera le dos à la
corse
cette course dont il avait pensé si
longtemps qu'elle renfermait sa destinée
il se trompait et cette île dont jean
jacques rousseau avait dit qu'elle
étendrait le monde est bien l l'étonnant
les faits on lui donne en napoléon
napoléon partant là par 7 mai
vers ce continent où devait s'accomplit
la plus extraordinaire d existence la
sienne
[Musique]